YUFENG GUO: Are you looking
to improve the reproducibility
and reliability of your data
science and machine learning
workflows and training jobs?
Then you've got try out
AI Platform Pipelines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode
we're going to explore how to
set up AI Platform Pipelines
to address your MLOps needs.
MLOps is all the
rage these days--
a combination of machine
learning and operations.
It applies many
DevOps best practices
to the machine
learning ecosystem.
We often hear
about how important
it is to have a well-running
continuous integration
and deployment pipeline
for software development.
So as your machine
learning setup matures,
you should begin to incorporate
these best practices as well.
AI Platform Pipelines allows
you to orchestrate your machine
learning workflows as
reproducible and reusable
pipelines.
Specifically, it
handles the process
of setting up Kubeflow Pipelines
with TensorFlow Extended
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
Let's talk a little more
about each of these terms.
Kubeflow is an
open-source toolkit
for running machine learning
workflows on Kubernetes.
Kubeflow Pipelines is
a component of Kubeflow
that provides a platform
for building and deploying
ML workflows, called
pipelines, structured
as directed acyclic graphs.
TensorFlow Extended, or TFX,
is also an open-source project,
which you can use to define
your TensorFlow-based machine
learning workflows
as a pipeline.
TFX provides a
Pipeline Template that
includes components you can
reuse to ingest and transform
data, train and
evaluate a model,
deploy a train model for
inference, and so on.
By reusing TFX components, you
can orchestrate your machine
learning process
without the need
to build custom components
for every single step.
Setting up AI Platform
Pipelines is quite easy.
The team has worked hard
to make this step as
simple as possible,
especially for those
who are not familiar with
Kubernetes or DevOps.
There's a dedicated dashboard
for our pipelines in the AI
Platform menu in Cloud Console.
From there, we can
deploy a new pipeline.
This button will
actually take us
to the Cloud Marketplace,
which is the same place we get
our deep learning VM images.
After we click Launch, we are
presented with a configuration
page which has two sections.
First, we need to either
create a Kubernetes cluster
or select an existing cluster.
Notice that this
is zone-specific.
If you're creating
a new cluster,
be sure to check the box to
allow access to cloud APIs.
This action grants the
cluster access to your project
and saves you the effort
of creating and managing
a service account or
creating a Kubernetes secret.
Once that's all set,
click Create Cluster
and then wait while
the cluster is created.
During this time, the necessary
VMs will be provisioned,
the Kubernetes cluster
will be created,
and the Kubernetes
software is installed.
What I really like
about this process
is that Kubernetes has been
abstracted away and automated.
Once your cluster is
created, all we need to do
is give our pipelines instance
a name and click Deploy.
Now, we wait some more
while the Kubeflow pipeline
software is installed.
Once Pipelines is
deployed to your cluster,
you end up mostly working in
the Pipelines Dashboard UI.
The Pipelines Dashboard uses
a left-hand navigation bar
with a number of
different categories,
beginning with
Getting Started which
contains a handful of
useful demos and tutorials
with examples of both TFX
and Kubeflow Pipelines.
Next up is the Pipelines Menu--
the main event and
the reason we're here.
We can see a list of
all our pipelines.
The setup process deployed a
few demo and tutorial pipelines
to the cluster so you can
get started right away.
Let's start by running
the data passing pipeline
by clicking on its name
and the Create Run button.
We can include it
in an experiment
or just leave the field
blank to associate
it with the default experiment
which acts as a catchall.
Notice that this pipeline
has no parameters,
so we can click Start without
entering any additional fields.
Now we have a pipeline running.
Notice the dashboard is now
showing us the list of runs
in the Experiments tab.
Let's click on our run
and see it in progress.
Notice the graph will animate
each component in the pipeline
as it runs.
After a little while,
the job is finished.
And the green check
replaces that timer icon.
Pipelines are like templates.
They define what needs to
be run but don't represent
the actual execution of code.
That's what runs are for.
You must run a pipeline in
order to get any output.
Each time you run a pipeline,
a new set of outputs
are produced.
These runs are single
executions of a pipeline.
And individual runs
are associated together
into an experiment.
You can name your experiments
whatever you want.
And you're not
constrained to having
the same type of pipeline
runs in one experiment.
So you can include
different types
of pipelines in the same
experiment if you want to.
Running pipelines
can output artifacts.
These artifacts are
viewed by drilling down
into an individual run, or
by clicking the Artifacts
tab in the left-hand menu.
Kubeflow Pipelines supports
the following output viewers
currently-- confusion matrix,
markdown, ROC curve, table,
TensorBoard, and even
a web app if you really
want to get fancy.
Now you might be
thinking, this pipelines
thing sounds really
awesome, but how
do I create my own pipeline?
At the end of the day, we
have two different ways
to make pipelines.
AI Platform Pipelines
supports both the TFX SDK
and the Kubeflow Pipelines SDK.
How do we choose
which one to use?
Well, if you're working
with TensorFlow, use TFX.
It's designed for TensorFlow and
will make your TensorFlow code
run seamlessly.
Otherwise, use
Kubeflow Pipelines.
It's designed for any
arbitrary library.
So you can run everything
from your scikit-learn models
to Py Torch in your pipeline.
TFX has the advantage of
more pre-built components
and is a more
opinionated approach,
while Kubeflow Pipelines
is more open-ended
and allows you to
design your own pipeline
components from scratch.
We'll be looking at
more details on how
to use these two SDKs in future
episodes of AI Adventures.
But for now, I've linked to
two longer videos exploring
AI Platform Pipelines in more
detail in the description
below.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
If you enjoyed it,
click that Like button
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
I'm Yufeng Guo on
Twitter @YufengG.
And if you're looking for longer
form machine learning and cloud
content, be sure to
check out the Adventures
in the Cloud YouTube channel,
which I have linked below
in the description.
For now, try setting up your
very own pipeline on GKE
using AI Platform Pipelines
on Google Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]